Throughout this unit, we've learned how to graph linear equations and linear
inequalities. We're going to wrap this unit up by talking about functions. All
the linear equations that we've encountered are actually functions and we're
going to learn why. Functions take some sort of input like Bob, they do
something mysterious to it, and then get an output like o. This mysterious part
is the part we're trying to figure out. It's the description or rule that
changes Bob into o. Here is the list of the names of some people. These are
going to be my input and here is a list of outputs. I'm going to pair each
person with an output by showing some errors. Bob goes to the letter o, Jill
goes to the letter i, and Ralph goes to the letter a, and so on. So in this
relation, what's the relationship between these inputs and these outputs? Finish
out this sentence using the best choice.